hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's a
whole bunch of Captain America Civil War
news going on right now they'd started
shooting the movie so I wanted to do a
video for Scarlet Witch and division
because they're both going to be in it
this is mostly gonna be about the top
five craziest Scarlet Witch and vision
storylines but just for context I'm
gonna reference some stuff from age of
Ultron so careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet as weird as them
having sex in the comics has been you
know them having phantom babies we kind
of have to look at how the Marvel films
have treated relationships particularly
the Russos you know Winter Soldier is a
good example like how it dealt with
romance between Black Widow in Captain
America they didn't have a relationship
or anything they they just had a lot of
chemistry and Black Widow kept poking
fun at Steve Rogers for not asking women
out just Whedon to get like a little
step further with the Black Widow Hulk
thing that's probably as close as we've
gotten in recent memory to like a
full-blown relationship it did feel like
Whedon was trying to lay some seeds for
Scarlet Witch and vision anytime two
characters in a big blockbuster movie
that have a long history together in the
comics stare deeply into each other's
eyes
yeah it's saying something when Captain
America Civil War picks up they'll have
been with the Avengers like the New
Avengers for a full year so something is
probably going to have happened in that
time span we're talking like Star Trek
data explore your emotions territory in
the context of the movies the two
characters actually share a lot in
common
they're both somewhat celestial children
scarlet witch's powers come from the
mind gem so divisions so here we go here
are my top five craziest Scarlet Witch
and vision storylines starting with
Avengers number 109 this is the first
time Scarlet Witch and visions started
to fall in love
you can thank Steve Englehart for that
he was the writer on the issue this is
way back in 1973 it's also the same
issue Hawkeye left the Avengers in
they've been this weird sexual tension
between him and Scarlet Witch and he got
really jealous when she started to fall
in love with vision and if that's not
like the death of interesting in a
storyline I don't know what is now this
is 1973 so you know comics are a little
bit sillier back then nowadays that
would be like the lifetime version of a
Marvel movie the whole story mostly
revolved around Hawkeye and his
departure from the Avengers but this was
just like the beginning of Scarlet Witch
envisioned Quicksilver also wasn't super
hot on the idea but but this was before
they had like the whole twincest Jaime
Cersei Game of Thrones thing going on so
his concern was mostly
next crazy story number four let all men
bring together
that's giant size Avengers volume number
four it involves two big weddings
Scarlet Witch gets married to vision and
mantis got married to a resurrected
sword man it was actually like the story
itself was part of this big celestial
Madonna saga where the Kree believed
that mantis would become this celestial
Madonna and give birth to like this
celestial Messiah already sounds super
crazy as part of that storyline vision
had been trying to learn about his
origins so he travels to the Dark
Dimension he finds Scarlet Witch is the
prisoner of Dormammu they have this big
battle with him they defeat him they
come back vision reveals his true
feelings for Scarlet Witch and they get
married to in it in addition to mantis
it was a really big event based
storyline but I loved the fact that they
threw Dormammu
in there too in addition to like this
big Kree storyline because that was the
1970s and it wasn't too long after
vision and Scarlet Witch started to you
know get together it was also a Steve
Englehart storyline moving out to the
next big crazy story The Scarlet Witch
gets pregnant with the vision using
magic so that was part of Scarlet Witch
and vision that was like an actual comic
by itself that was actually a limited
series by itself they had taken a leave
from The Avengers and just got gone off
on their own as crazy as this sounds
Scarlet Witch used the mystic force of
the population of New Salem in order to
warp reality and get pregnant now you're
starting to see why joss whedon rein
back her powers just a little bit like
in the Marvel movie universe she's not
gonna be that powerful at the end of
that series in issue 12 she gave birth
the name that story was actually
double-sized climax you can make as many
sex jokes as you want about that they
name the twins Thomas and William as
crazy as them having babies and turning
to this is like a big you know soapy
family drama next big crazy storyline is
when they retcon that that's Avengers
West Coast number 52 the name of the
storyline was fragments of a greater
darkness so you did you know fragments
of Mephisto that's where her twins are
supposed to be this was John Byrne
writing so John Byrne is the one that
retcon scarlet witch's children Agatha
Harkness temporary erased scarlet
witch's memory of her children so that
she wouldn't go crazy but she ended up
remembering by Avengers West Coast
number 62 so within about ten issues she
remembered she had phantom children on
to number two crazy storyline Avengers
Children's Crusade number nine this was
Scarlet Witch getting tired of being
defined by her relationships with other
characters so she finally leaves this is
like the big break between her and the
rest of the Avengers it was in this same
storyline that iron lad destroyed the
vision and the team has to like decide
whether or not to rebuild him they had a
big falling out over visions romance
with Cassie it really is like a soap
opera with this bunch so I'm gonna
assume that the movies are gonna
sidestep a lot of this but if you really
want to dig deep into this it's all
there
Children's Crusade is like a storyline
picked up around 2010 it was all about
repairing a lot of the damage from house
of M weakened in speed were supposedly
the reincarnation of scarlet witch's
children and then finally my number one
crazy Scarlet Witch in visions storyline
Avengers disassembled they started with
Avengers issue number 500 Scarlet Witch
blames the Avengers for the deaths of
her children and like all the bad things
that have happened to her and she ends
up destroying vision and in a bunch of
the people she ends up killing a whole
bunch of people
this of course built up to the house of
M no more mutants moment so that that's
why it's so awesome and so crazy crazy
stories like this I you know I wouldn't
go out and buy the issues save your
money for Secret Wars get Marvel
unlimited so you can check out some of
these like ridiculous old storylines
slightly less crazy during like John
Byrne Brian Michael Bendis era but you
get the idea in the context of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe like Captain
America Civil War
they'll probably address relationship
stuff like this in like less than 10
minutes of a two-and-a-half-hour movie
they got a crammed as many action
sequences as they can in there I think
the Russos do sexual tension really well
so I'm hoping for something closer to
what Black Widow and Captain America had
going on a Winter Soldier not a
full-blown romance but a lot of subtext
a lot of things that probably went
unsaid clearly Joss Whedon decided not
to pick that up and run with it
but the roosters are back on the case so
expect a lot more moments like we saw in
Winter Soldier between the characters
because a man's coming up really soon
I'm probably gonna do like a fun ant-man
bonus video next week so be sure to
subscribe to get that I might even try
to get it out by Saturday in case you
don't know the date it's actually July
17th that's when the movie is coming out
I think what I want I might do is like a
Hank Pym villain storyline video just
because there have been some times in
the comics when he has been less than
what you would call a hero in case you
guys haven't seen it I did a Scarlet
Witch video a while ago you can click
here it's all about just like her
storylines in the comics and you can
click here to learn all about the
asked of Captain America's Civil War
couple surprises thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you